à la première session de skate des
jeunes j'ai senti ce plaisir de glisser
sur la planche et direct approché j'ai
commencé le souhaitent de six ans
maintenant je devais avoir 12 ou 13 ans
au collège s'étaient tous les week-ends
tous les mercredis après midi en
arrivant au lycée après c'est devenu mon
transport quotidien j'avais toujours ma
plante avec moi mon entourage me dit de
bouquet chez afrique du skate et je
pense qu'à ça je parle que de ça tg pour
l'assiette
ils ont le même âge 18 ans le même
prénom quentin et la même passion le
skate l'un via des hommes l'autre près
de bourges et cette planche à roulettes
qui glisse sauter s'envolent les fascine
comme elle a fasciné des générations
d'adolescents depuis le début des années
cinquante moyen de déplacement plutôt
écolo pour certains loisirs pour
d'autres à l'origine le skateboard est
un sport extrême inventé par des
surfeurs californiens en mal de vagues
tente un bonnet veut devenir champion de
skate
cette année il va trouver une façon
rapide hausse ok quand à ma il fait bon
on va pouvoir profiter aux blindes genre
si je fais un tout petit ventre le tour
de la piste
et puis après on commencera un peu par
le flag par le street jusqu'à 2h de
street avec les strictes règles strictes
flou et on finira par le bol comme ça
que je joue encore en championnat si
vous n'aimez pas trop de fumée on dit ce
chauffeur de taxi
platts football dans le monde du skate
speak english
des mots qui désignent des zones du
skate park le flat une route lice le bol
le front une piscine vide et le street
art en place urbaine dans des
environnements différents le rider doit
réaliser des tricks c'est à dire des
figures et ce sont elles qui rapporte
des points pour pouvoir en marquer un
maximum
quentin s'entraîne jusqu'à cinq heures
paris cédait des nombreuses heures de
travail à essayer des figures à tomber à
se faire mal à travailler à recommencer
c'est un casse-tête possible les gens
ils prennent entre guillemets pour
un jeune qui roule pour ça désir pose
des tas mais ce qu'ils savent pas c'est
que derrière
ouais pas moi je travaille chez les
compétitions commenté un peu plus avec
un peu plus vite et je pense que pour la
première fois à tokyo en 2020 le skate
board sera une discipline olympique il
ce rendez vous se prépare dès
aujourd'hui si on fait bien les
compagnies fédéral pendant un an deux
ans peut-être qu'il y aura une chance
peut-être qu'ils puissent se trouver en
équipe de france ça c'est la douleur qui
nous dira mais l'entraînement surtout il
faut qu'il travail travail travail et la
chose qu'on a ici à châteauroux c'est
que cetto m voici qu'on a on a les
structures pour pour l'entraînement on a
une robe couverte on a un beau là où
dort en extérieur et puis une aire de
street qui est parfaite en fait qui
pourra permettre normalement d'abord il
ya contaminera aussi les petits jeunes
qui m'ont sud est rien puisque ça va
être un fardeau mais quentin est un
jeune homme comme les autres
il ya quelques mois il a obtenu son
diplôme des chauffagistes et avant de
chercher un travail
ils rêvent de décrocher les étoiles on a
tous venez vous
puis des frérots il laisse en plan soit
là tu te fais des vous sincèrement j'ai
eu peur début je me disais le skate
c'est pas si c'est pas un métier mais
bon là il a métier en poche il peut
sacrifier une année de sa vie pour
réessayer de réaliser son rêve
sa collection de planches plus d'une
vingtaine des images qui décorent les
murs de sa chambre
chaque soir quand un s'endort sur la
planète skate une question d'équilibré
quand j'ai des problèmes chez du skate
comme ça j'y pense que ça le canalise
aussi comme ça déchu trop énervé dès que
je suis petit je vais faire du skate
comme ça à saman s'amuse fois et comme
selon moi je suis sûr normes hier soir
de chez pas de conneries à la place fin
de métier canaliser l'énergie de ces
jeunes fous de la glisse et on faire un
atout un pari pour la métropole de
châteauroux l'alliance des rebelles de
la rampe et des politiques locaux cette
union en apparence contre nature abouti
à la création du seul skatepark en béton
intégré de cette qualité à 300
kilomètres à la ronde
devenu en très peu de temps le spot du
centre de la france on avait mis dans
notre projet cet outil qui étaient déjà
prévus sur ce site par l'ancienne
municipalité
mais on a concrétisé sa en travaillant
avec le club local et tous les acteurs
locaux du state pour que ce soit un
outil qui soit travailler en
concertation avec ce qu'il utiliserait
pas relation ce qui nous a motivés c'est
la volonté de changer l'image de la
ville
on est une ville moyenne de province on
a besoin de faire parler de nous
positivement et tout ce qui peut nous
donner une image jeune une image aussi
de haute performance de technicité nous
a amenés justement à réfléchir à ce
projet c'est un investissement important
on est à 600 mille euros donc c'est
quand même pas anodin comme
investissement et on prend ce paris-là
d'en faire un véritable outil qui à la
fois répondre à la demande de la
population mais attirera également des
skateurs de toute la région et de toute
la france
ça peut faire trente ans qu'on essaye
d'avoir ce parc
on a mis ça a mis du temps mais
maintenant il est qui n'osera pas
j'espère pas
je réussis pas plat année neuf ans et je
pense que bon on aurait progressé
largement plus vite et puis bon on
aurait travaillé plus de choses on
aurait fait beaucoup plus de sorties
beaucoup plus de comptes est beaucoup
plus peut-être une carrière en plein
plein de choses quoi je partir pas là
parfois là je passe au dessus de la
torche et arrive dans les bras sa
carrière quentin du bo lui il a déjà
lancé entameront le championnat d 1016
parmi les 10 premiers skateurs français
pendant ses études de commerce il avait
effectué un stage dans une boutique en
lien avec sa passion
quand il le peut et skate à châteauroux
mais sa vie est ici dans la cité
berruyère le bac en poche il a tout
naturellement choisi de travailler comme
gardien et médiateur sur l'actuelle
skatepark de bourges dans le cadre d'une
mission de service civique
un bon moyen de s'entraîner au quotidien
et d'explorer le skate toutes ses
facettes à l'heure actuelle je pense que
c'est des disciplines qui ont monté au
niveau national en 2020 sont va être
accepté en tant que discipline olympique
donc je pense qu'on va gagner un peu en
notoriété je vais dire surtout en
crédibilité et on va peut-être avoir
l'étiquette de réelles sportif et
peut-être que là on pourra espérer
d'avoir de meilleures infrastructures ce
qui permettrait à bourges d'avoir
pourquoi pas des athlètes pouvant
postuler pour de grandes compétitions de
skate park permet de m'entraîner
quotidiennement après pas à la hauteur
je le souhaiterais contrairement à ce
qu'il ya pu y avoir il ya une dizaine
une vingtaine d'années à bourges heureux
les adeptes du skate board à bourges
qu'ils ont leurs pistes depuis
aujourd'hui en fait trois rangs installé
dans le parc du foyer des jeunes
travailleurs de la charmille
ce sont les membres du club eux mêmes
qui ont conçu et fabriqué cette
réalisation inauguré cet après midi en
présence du gratin national et
international du skateboard vous demande
de penser qu'on sait des pistes qu'on
souhaite par des américains donc pour
les jeunes s'étaient déjà valent plus
que valorisant et puis pour tout le
monde mais le challenge du retour au
milieu des années 80 cette trempe de 14
mètres de large
unique en europe à l'époque est
installée au prado a été entièrement
fait maison
elle a ouvert un véritable âge d'or du
skateboard à bourges
sous l'impulsion de 7 tonnes nicolas
malinowsky les meilleurs mondiaux il ya
quelques années aussi étrange que cela
puisse paraître on était vraiment le
le point de chute européen du skate ici
à bourges au prado on a pu voir défiler
mike magee est l'inventeur du 540 enfin
un tour et demi en l'air sur un skate
kif stephenson kevin staab mark gonzalez
qu'un génie de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui le stud skate et puis bon la
légende du skate tony hawk quoi alors
ici vous aviez deux rampes deux grosses
rampe de renommée internationale qui
étaient installés dont une qui a qui
pouvait être démontable et transportable
pour de l'événementiel et qui a été
installée notamment
milieu des bassins du trocadéro à paris
c'était en 1988
prenez une rampe la plus grande d'europe
un public de fans quelques cinglés et
vous aurez un aperçu du 11e championnat
de france organisé ce week-end en 1990
les berrichons associés organiseront la
coupe d'europe au palais d'auron
mais les années 2000 seront celles du
déclin des installations de la charmille
vieillissante et mal entretenu
disparaîtront lors de la destruction du
foyer des jeunes travailleurs
entre temps et en attendant mieux
quelques modules ont été mises en place
en centre ville sur la place séraucourt
jusqu'au jour où je suis passé devant le
skate parc et j'ai vu qu'il y avait plus
rien en fait il y avait un panneau comme
quoi ça avait été détruit on n'avait pas
été prévenu j'ai appelé le président de
l'aso j'ai appelé différents membres
pour savoir si en fait peut-être
quelqu'un avait été contacté personne
avait été contactée donc j'ai découvert
ça comme ça et puis j'ai appelé moi mon
initiative la mairie en fait qui m'a dit
que oui ça avait été fait dans l'urgence
et qu'il n'avait pas eu le temps de
prévenir les associations et puis a eu
de nouveau skatepark qu'il ya eu des
discussions aussi ensuite mais on
m'avait conseillé de ne pas faire comme
ça puisque c'est complètement inadaptés
second nous secondes et pratiquants
c'est démotivant
ça c'est une bonne discipline c'est
intergénérationnel il ya autant des
jeunes que des anciens qui viennent tout
le monde se parle tout le monde échange
n'y a pas de compétition et de la
motivation tout le monde s'entraide et
tout le monde se tout le monde est
content quand tout le monde réussie mais
le nouveau skate park et et comme on dit
petit et une fois qu'il y a une bonne
dizaine de pratiquants de sub elle
deviendrait même quasiment dangereux
cet épisode a douché les espoirs des
riders berruyer je croyais dur comme fer
à la création d'un skate park en béton
ils ont même présenté un projet resté
lettre morte
la porte est ouverte
le dialogue n'est pas rompu voilà c'est
aussi à eux de revenir me voir il ya
aucun problème quand on est je travaille
mon sens pour que nous ayons pas skate
park à donges est ce qu'on peut
s'engager sur une date
vu que les 100 en 2020 parce qu'avant le
maire s'est engagé sur 2018
lors de voila c'est écrit c'est dans la
presse donc il va falloir travailler
pour présenter un projet dans le budget
2010 8 voire de business parce que on
travaille aussi sur plusieurs lignes
une question de priorité et d'intérêt
peut-être que vivent de bourges a
préféré investir dans d'autres domaines
que celui de sports extrêmes que c'est
peut être encore moins connu dans notre
région alors que ça peut marcher
lorsqu'elle parc peut amener le
pratiquant d'un autre pays à venir ici
juste pour pouvoir rouler cette
infrastructure là un mode de vie une
philosophie aller d'un spot à l'autre à
la découverte de skate park tous
différents comme un golfeur à la
recherche d'un nouveau parcours à la
rencontre d'autres passionnés aussi
sur facebook on suit ouais c'est ça son
cours à 21 heures un autre puisque est
ensemble on est toujours là je dirais
voilà c'est ça il en a qui va mettre un
truc que l'on permette de répondre
exempt de scotchés à leurs rivalités cas
intéressante les quais pas forcément
méchant coup
pour est intéressant on produise une
vidéo tous les deux qu'on est au final
dans une vie différente on n'est pas si
loin de tes piémont se ressemblent sur
pas mal de vent alors toucher plus de
monde à dos au final pouvoir pourquoi
pas à recruter des sponsors ou voulait
de quelle qu'elle soit pouvoir à bassens
et centristes c'est ça diouf dit que les
comtés en carrés vont se mettre en
quatre pour atteindre un jour peut-être
le sommet de la rampe
les